these approaches are useful in machine
learning and can do useful things for
you so it's going to be a bit of a
whirlwind tour of some topological data
analysis techniques I'm not going to
cover everything in the field or even a
small portion of it but it's more to
give you an idea and a taste of why this
sort of approach is worth learning more
about and at the end of the day the goal
of this is to build some sound
mathematical theory but still at the end
of the day have useful practical
applications so we're going to start off
covering a little bit of the
mathematical theory at a high level just
kind of give you a general flavor of how
this approach thinks about data and then
we're going to go through and look at
how this could be applied in practice on
some more real-world problems so to
start with we're gonna have a short
primer on topology so the first thing I
want to introduce to you is this notion
of simplices now these are little tiny
building blocks of dimensional spaces so
a zero simplex there is simply a point
that's easy a one simplex you build by
putting together two two zero simple C's
and just assuming there's some span
between those things a two simplex you
put together three zero szimpla C's and
just fill in the convex hull span and so
on up so you can create a very simple
object of however many dimensions you
like the key here is that I just built
them up in a very simple combinatorial
way so you can actually deal with
complex continuous topology in a way
that just works in simple finite
combinatorial terms that you can put on
a computer in an easy way so these
aren't very interesting spaces but you
can glue together these simplices along
their faces and build a thing called a
simplicial complex that's just a bunch
of these simplices all glued together in
a useful sort of way and the key here is
that pretty much any interesting
topological space that you're going to
account encounter and data analysis can
be built in exactly this way
not all topological spaces topology is a
pretty broad subject it has nasty
horrible pathological spaces that do
very nasty things and you want to avoid
those and these won't represent those
but that's okay because we're
essentially never going to encounter
them so this model of building topology
is good enough to do the job and as I
said the key here is it's all finite
combinatorial simple to work with on a
computer so next is a theorem and this
is a picture of a theorem you don't have
to read the theorem or understand what
it's saying the meat of what's going on
here is that it's telling us that if you
construct a simplicial complex in a
suitable way from some data it's going
to capture all the relevant topology of
that space you built it from so if you
have one of these interesting
topological spaces with all this
continuous infinite dynamics you can
turn that into a simple finite
combinatorial object the simplicial
complex and capture most everything you
need to know and that's really all this
theorem is saying but what it means is
that there's a lot of actual deep rich
underlying mathematics that formalizes
all of this and makes it all sound so
let's have an example so we can see sort
of what we're talking about here so
let's take some points some data and
color code it by position on a manifold
this sort of a warped linear manifold
going on here amongst this data and what
we're going to do is we're going to
create an open cover of it which is
really just placing an open ball around
each point and this gives us a cover of
the space and then we're going to take
the the nerve of it that was the what
that nerve theorem was talking about and
all that really is is whenever two of
these balls intersect I'm going to draw
one simplex between the two points
whenever three of those balls intersect
each other in a triple intersection I'm
going to draw - simplex convex hull
around the the three points and so on up
and that's all we're really doing that
sounds really simple and it sounds kind
of too simplistic to work but that
theorem tells us that in fact it
captures the topology we care about
so there's deep underlying math that
tells us that this should actually work
and in this case that does actually
capture a lot of that structure we were
caring about this is a really toys on
pole so you know you probably could have
inferred this yourself just by staring
at it but it's gonna work in much higher
dimensional spaces and more complex
examples later now you should also note
that this didn't entirely work it's not
really perfect and we're gonna come back
to why that's not working later when we
start trying to apply this in more
practical terms so the next thing I want
to go through is a bunch of language
from math that are underlying ideas that
matter I I don't need you to understand
the formal definitions of these things
but I want to introduce you to these
sorts of words and ways of thinking
about things because what is involved
here is that while I'm going to explain
the intuition of what these things mean
there's a rigorous formalism that
actually makes these general intuitive
ideas that are allowed to explain true
so what is a functor well it's
essentially a function between domains
of discourse and that sounds very
general but what we're talking about
here is something like taking the nerve
of that open cover we started with a
topological splay space which is
continuous and complicated and we turned
it into this finite combinatorial object
where we could just work in pure
combinatoric sland
so in from topology to combinatorics and
having a functor is basically a formal
way of saying no no we can do this in a
fully rigorous way that makes sense I'm
not you're not just waving your hands
and going well something like that it's
for analyzable and in a junction is
basically having a pair of functors that
go back and forth between two different
domains of discourse and what it's
really saying is you have a way of
translating back and forth from one to
the other that's not quite perfect but
it's closed as close as you can get to
an equivalence between these two
different domains of discourse Oh keep
going I'll take questions at the end
sorry all right
so the next one is a limit
so the way to think about this is a
solution to a system of constraints and
by system of constraints I really mean
in a very general sense here but the key
is that once again you can actually
formalize all of this but the intuitions
are the right sort of intuitions to take
we can find the solution that's going to
solve this constraint system in a
formalized will mathematical way and
alternatively Co limits magically glue
together complex systems of objects into
a single coherent whole in the simplest
possible way according to this
underlying theory of mathematics that's
doing all this this is all incredibly
abstract and I've hand waved about the
intuitions of what these words mean but
do they actually do anything in practice
that's what we really want to know so
what can we use all this abstract
nonsense that I've been talking about
for well first of all let's start with
dimension reduction that's a common
problem in unsupervised learning you
have some very high dimensional data and
you'd like to either be able to
visualize it or at least get it down to
a low enough dimension that you could
say run clustering on it or something
like that and you want to reduce the
dimension of it in a way that tries to
preserve as much of the structure of the
data as possible well what do we mean by
the structure of the data well we're
talking about the interrelationships
between the different data points and
when you're talking about
interrelationships you're really talking
about topology so topology is the right
mathematics to use to tackle this
problem so let's go back to our example
that we had earlier there was a nice toy
example and this didn't work and the
question you should be asking yourself
is why was this not actually doing what
that theorem said it would well the
theorem said that it's had an open cover
of the topological space and if you
remember back when I drew those balls
over each of the points the little
circles around them it didn't cover the
whole space there were gaps between them
and so there was a notional manifold in
between that we weren't covering so
that's what it's not capturing so really
our problem was that the data was not
uniform
only distributed on the manifold there
were gaps in the data if we just took a
uniform sized ball around each point if
the data was uniformly distributed on
the manifold then this would be great
and it would all work and if you you
know redistribute that data so it's nice
and uniform along this notional manifold
that we had you can see we would get all
the intersections would want and this
would reduce down to topologically just
a nice sequence of lines so that is what
we want we want data to be uniformly
distributed on our manifold when is that
ever true in practice with real-world
data well the answer is it's not so how
do I a mathematician deal with this
problem I just assume it to be true
because I can but that actually has
implications if I assume the data is
uniformly distributed on this manifold
that means something about how the
manifold itself is structured so what
that has to mean is that there's some
notion of distance on this manifold that
is different than whatever the ambient
space is implying that makes this data
uniformly distributed so I have to find
how to reinterpret my notion of distance
locally around each point so that the
data is uniformly distributed so a quick
refresher on manifolds manifolds and
manifold learning get tossed around a
lot in data science and machine learning
and no one usually goes to the trouble
of actually defining what they're
talking about they just being a curvy
surface II space type thing now in
practice mathematically what we mean is
that it's a thing where you can take a
small region of that space and it should
look exactly like standard Euclidean
space or at least have a natural map to
it so there's a bunch of patches that
all can be glued together to form this
manifold and each of those patches we
can map to a nice Euclidean space that
makes sense and everything's standard
and normal there so in a sense what
we're doing here is saying that each of
these patches is going to have a
different notion of distance a different
way of rescaling itself and
so under that notion of distance the
data is going to be uniformly
distributed so that's that's that's how
we're gonna cheat and make the data
uniformly distributed okay there's
another assumption that I'm going to
make and that is that the manifold is
locally connected and you don't need
right now to worry about what that means
what it means in practice is that those
nasty pathological topological spaces
that I talked about that are going to
ruin everything and not be able to be
modeled with some political complex what
happened
we're going to get rid of those by
requiring this to be true we don't want
a nasty Horrible's topological space
that's not going to work out so if we
combine all that together we end up with
an open cover that looks more like this
where it's going to be fuzzy as their
confidence in this notion of distance
around a given point declines it's gonna
be solid out to the first point so that
we're locally connected and it's gonna
fade away from there because we don't
really know that much about the metric
we're gonna lose confidence in it as we
go but we left something out which is
that all these local metrics that under
fining are incompatible
so we approximated a different notion of
distance around each data point and I
might have one data point that thinks
that this other data point over here is
really close but this data point over
here might think that this data point is
really far away they're not going to
agree on how far away each other are so
how can we deal with that well what's
going on is that in manifold land in the
nice theoretical sense there's these
patches that locally look like are in
but wherever they overlap there's down
at the bottom of of this diagram there's
actually maps given for how to map
between overlaps between these and with
their finite data we don't have that
we're lacking it that's the theoretical
data that will make this a nice metaphor
and we're just short of that so what can
we do well I talked about Co limits and
said it was the notional right way to
just glue a whole bunch of stuff
together into a sort of simplest
possible object that glues it all in a
natural way so we should glue these
metric spaces together
with Cola nuts would be the way to think
about this in these topological terms
the problem is that metric spaces the
category of metric spaces doesn't have
Cola mutts you actually just can't do
that it doesn't work so how do we get
around that problem well the solution is
to transfer our problem to a different
domain
whenever you get stuck in one domain
change your way of looking at the
problem work with it in a different
space and maybe there it'll be easier so
it turns out that there's more nice
theory again this is a picture of a
theorem you don't need to care about the
details it's more just saying a theorem
exists and all it's really saying is
that we can transfer these metric spaces
over to some other space of fuzzy
simplicial sets again don't worry about
the details right now where maybe this
stuff can work and importantly this is
in a junction and I talked about that
that's basically saying it's sort of a
minimal translation back and forth that
does is good a job of being accurate
going back and forth between these two
different domains as possible so this is
kind of an optimal translation between
these two different domains of discourse
metric spaces and this other space where
we can take Co limits and this whole
thing resolves itself very simply so
what we get out is a fuzzy simplicial
set which looks a lot like those
simplicial complexes we were just
talking about earlier in fact that's
exactly how you should think about it
the math is slightly different but the
intuition is entirely the same the only
difference is it's now fuzzy in the
sense that some of those simplest C's
are more there than others so the
existence of a simplex sort of has a
probabilistic notion it's sort of a
probability that this edge exists in the
graph and you should perhaps think of it
that way if that's much easier it's
really just a probabilistic graph its
vertices which were our data points and
edges where there's a probability that
that edge exists so suppose now we were
given a low dimensional representation
of the data how are we given it well
maybe we just started with randomly
distributed data it might not be very
good low dimensional representation but
it is one maybe we can do better and
find a better initialization a better
starting point there are natural ways to
do that but let's just assume we got one
by a some approach so we can apply the
same process I just talked about to get
a probabilistic graph associated to that
data and now all we have to do is ask
ourselves how close is this to the one
that our source data generated and
there's a natural way to write that down
as sort of a cross entropy type equation
I mean these are Bernoulli probabilities
we can just do cross entropy that makes
sense and that measures how close each
graph is to the other and then because
there's gradients we can associate with
this we can just do a gradient descent
and move the data around in the low
dimensional space until we get a result
that gives us a graph that looks as
close as possible to the one from the
high dimensional space so what we're
really saying is we want the topological
structure in the low dimensional space
to look as much like the topological
structure in the high dimensional space
as possible so in practice this is kind
of a force directed graph layout
algorithm and what that means is we've
got this term on the left which is going
to basically pull together points that
are quite closely connected and pull
things into clumps that are sort of
close together in the high dimensional
space and alternatively wherever things
are far apart in the high dimensional
space it's gonna this other right-hand
term is going to push them apart so one
side of this equation is going to get
the clumps right the other side of this
equation is going to eat get the gaps
right and that's gonna be how we're
gonna get our low dimensional
representation so the question is that
you should be asking yourselves at this
point that was a nice explanation of
some math but I bet it doesn't really
work which is a fair question
so does it actually work in practice on
real data this isn't quite real data but
it's close enough
this is illness digits data so these are
handwritten digits in AZ 28 by 28 pixel
grayscale images so 28 by 28 pixels ends
up being 784 dimensions so we started
with
180 four-dimensional data and we found
the topological representation in only
two dimensions that most closely
approximates that and I've colored this
by the actual number that that
handwritten digit represents and what
you'll see is that you've got down in
the bottom left corner a long tall
skinny clump of ones on the far right
hand side you've got the zeros and then
you've got groups of digits that look
kind of similar like 4 7 & 9 up in the
top left corner or 8 5 & 3 in the middle
and if you think about you know how
those digits would look when handwritten
they do look kind of similar to each
other
it's pull them apart in two distinct
clumps but it does a good enough job
here's that algorithm running on fashion
evenness to data so this is images of
fashion items things like bags shirts
dresses boots sandals and so on and you
see it's separated out most of the
classes it hasn't done a perfect job
which you should always be suspicious
when somebody presents you only perfect
solutions but it's done about as well as
one might hope and it's done things that
make sense like separating out the
trousers and the footwear as clearly
distinct clumps that are the footwear is
all together there's boots and sandals
and sneakers on the right hand side
there and then trousers separated out
well down in the bottom so it's doing a
pretty good job another example this is
Kazushi in Nastase is handwritten
Japanese calligraphy characters there
are quite a few different classes of
these and you can see again it still
does a remarkable job of picking out the
right classes and pulling them apart in
a nice way so overall this is working
pretty well in practice but we've got
some good theory behind this so we can
go even further we could do something
along the lines of metric learning so
here is an approach with Siamese and
triplet networks from the fashion
illness data set and the goal here is to
take the labeled data and use that label
information to try and find an embedding
of the
data that best respects the labels and
this is using fancy neural networks to
do that job this is about as well as it
does on the left hand side is the
embedding of the training set and then
we have new data samples and what we
want to be able to do is embed them in
their existing embedding and get out a
result that should hopefully still have
distances be meaningful in that space
but if we used the approach I've just
been describing to do that sort of thing
we get something like this now again
it's not perfect you can see on the on
the case in the right and the test set
there's cases where data has been
misclassified in a sense but not only
have we separated out the classes all
pretty cleanly there's internal
structure to each of those in the in the
earlier example you just get blobs but
here each of those clusters has an
internal structure that makes sense so
there's metric information within the
classes as well so we're learning quite
a lot about our data via this approach
so there's I feel a good example of how
apology can actually do a really useful
practical job okay here's another thing
you could do with topology word
embeddings now this is still a little
bit of work in progress I wanted to
share it anyway my colleague John Healy
who's in the audience will give a talk
later on tomorrow which will cover
related ideas and even get into some of
this in a little more detail it's also
work with : we're at the tattoo
Institute where I work I'm gonna just
run through it fairly quickly so the the
general idea behind word embeddings like
word Tuvok and glove and fast text and
related algorithms the core idea at the
heart of it all is something called the
distributional hypothesis of language
and that's summarized by this this quote
from John Firth which is that you shall
know a word by the company it keeps so
in a sense another way to think about
that is if you want to know what a word
means the first thing you're going to do
is say what can you use it in a sentence
for me and maybe if you have it used in
a sentence you can learn a bit about
what it means if you have it used in a
lot of sentences maybe you could
actually
to learn a lot so this is the core idea
that's going into this sort of approach
interestingly all the fancy math I
talked about in terms of category theory
with functors and limits and so on
actually has a theorem that says that
this should actually work it's called
the your natal EMA and this is actually
it turns out really just an intuitive
Restatement of that deep underlying
mathematical fact
which i think is just a you decide but
we'll leave it there so what we're gonna
do is represent a word as a multinomial
distribution of the words that a
co-occurs with so one way to think about
that is if you want to define a word by
using it a lot of sentences you could
make up a document of all the sentences
that use that word in some giant
training corpus so I'm just going to
pull out just the sentences that use
this one word stick them all together
and call that a big document and how do
you deal with documents well you make a
bag of words model of it and you just
got counts of how many times each
different word in the vocabulary is used
and that's how we're representing our
word
we're representing it as the document of
all uses of that word and air training
corpus and then we're going to turn that
into a multinomial by just normalizing
it to get the probabilities so the
downside of that is it's a very large
and very sparse matrix what I mean is
it's super high dimensional its
vocabulary sized dimensional so this
could easily be twenty thousand a
hundred thousand dimensional data how do
you usefully use that representation
well the goal would be to find the
manifold on which the words lie so here
we're going back to that assumption of
locally connected and that's what's
going to save us from this very very
high dimensional data because it turns
out one of the problems with high
dimensional data is it just doesn't
behave the way you normally think it
does so here's a plot of just the
distribution of distances to the twenty
nearest neighbors of just random
Gaussian distribution
in two dimensions and blue eight
dimensions in green thirty two
dimensions in red 128 dimensions in
purple and you can see the trend of
where this is going all these distances
just move further and further up in high
dimensional space all the senses are
really quite large now generally you
only really care about how distances
compare to each other so effectively
you're going to normalize all the
distances back by dividing essentially
by the largest distance well if we did
that with these distances what we get is
this and now as we go up dimensions
everything's at least on the same scale
but the very high dimensional distances
are now an incredibly narrow spike so
essentially in high dimensional spaces
all distances look essentially
equivalently the same so it's you can't
tell the difference between different
distances between different objects
everything looks the same distance away
from everything else but if we take this
locally connected assumption into
account and apply that as we go what we
get is this and here we see now that the
distribution of distances under this
transformation stays pretty much the
same as we go up dimensions so we can
work in ridiculously high dimensional
spaces and still retain all the
information we want and that came not
from some heuristic but from a deep
underlying fact about what we wanted the
topological space to look like it should
be locally connected so now it's just a
matter of finding the kink and correct
metric to work from multinomial
parameter space and for that you need to
go to information geometry from the 50s
which basically constructed a whole
theory of distributions living on a
manifold and there's geodesic distances
between distributions on manifolds this
is all fine you you push it all through
and there's a closed-form formula that's
actually surprisingly simple I believe
it's in John's talk and you can see it
there the end result is that this is an
example of Yelp reviews embedded with
this approach so these are all words
from Yelp reviews and you can see that
even though we went from a ridiculously
high dimensional representation of this
data down to just two via this approach
it's cat
should huge amounts of information about
similarity among words there's faucet
and baths and showers and dryers up in
the top right hand corner down in the
bottom you've got all the different
kinds of food over to the side of that
on the right-hand side next to all the
food aren't all the drinks and it has
understood a huge amount of information
about the data just from looking at how
words co-occur with each other
vectorizing that and then reducing the
dimension via manifold learning
technique that i just described in the
previous section so not only can we do
dimension reduction we can do word
embeddings with topology what else can
we do
well how about clustering that's another
big outstanding problem in unsupervised
learning there are lots of clustering
techniques
what would a topological clustering
technique look like well first we have
to ask what we mean by a cluster because
it's hard to define clusters well there
are lots of different definitions
opinion what exactly is the outcome
you're trying to achieve from this so
for our purposes here I'm going to
follow a density based clustering notion
that sort of follows Hartigan and other
ideas like that so the goal is that a
cluster is a connected component of a
super little set of the probability
density function of the underlying and
unknown distribution from which the data
samples were drawn you should probably
ask what that means it's fair let's look
at an example work through it and it'll
all be quite clear here's some test data
and let's look at what that means on
this test data set for clustering
there's notionally some sort of heat map
of the probability density function that
was underlying this data this data was
drawn from some probability density
function where data is more likely to
occur in some areas of the space less
likely to occur in others as you could
imagine there's a heat map where the
purple is the very likely for dado to
occur the yellow is rather unlikely and
so on that's a probability density
function from which the data was drawn
we can take level sets on that that
makes perfect sense
and you should be able to pick a given
sort of level set contour line and look
at that now
given this particular choice of contour
line there are connected components
basically different groups there and
each of those is going to lasso a
different group of data and each of
those groups of data that are going to
be less ood that's going to be our
clusters and any data that's not less
ood by that contour line that's just
going to be background noise that we're
not going to worry about so how do we
compute any of that without knowing this
probability density function because if
we knew that we would really pretty much
be done from the start the whole point
is you have some data and it just showed
up you don't know how it was generated
so let's take some even more toy data
just to work through this example and
see how this could work
so here's our very toy data set and the
assumption is that the data is
distributed on the manifold according to
some probability density function not
uniformly distributed but according to
some probability density function so
what if when we are doing our approach
instead of choosing a Romani and metric
that makes the that a uniformly
distributed we choose one that makes the
data preserves that distribution or in
fact importantly because there's often
noise and data emphasizes that
distribution to try and filter out a lot
of that noise well we can do that we're
gonna run into the same problem we had
before all their local metrics are going
to be incompatible with each other
potentially so how could we solve that
well really we want the minimal possible
solution to this so this time around
we're really more solving this as a
system of constraints so we should be
taking limits but once again metric
spaces limits it doesn't work as well as
you'd like so what we want to do is
change your domain of discourse change
how we're thinking about this problem to
somewhere else where all this formalism
goes through cleanly and we can do that
we already saw that the theorem that
says how to go about doing that so now
what we get is again if you like a
probabilistic graph you can imagine
higher dimensional simplices involved in
this
and again I colored it essentially by
the probability of the edge existing and
you can see that in a sense we've
actually captured some notion of the
topology of that probability density
function with that approach so we have
managed to turn this into something that
captures that elusive unknown
probability density function or at least
the topology of it so now there's a
magical functor that goes from
simplicial complexes to they're
connected components and it really is as
simple as you think it's just the
connected components of the thing that
turns a simplicial complex into a sit
we're changing from one domain of
discourse simplicial complexes to a
simple one since well we had a fuzzy
simplicial complex so instead we get a
fuzzy set so it's a fuzzy set of
connected components and as long as we
exclude components that are below a
minimum threshold of cluster size and
sort points by their component
membership we can get a thing that looks
sort of like this here are the points
along the along the x axis of sort of
the points according to which cluster
they belong to win and the membership
strength running up the y axis there and
you can pick out clusters from this
according to their membership strengths
and all sorts of ways you can use
information theoretic techniques you can
use persistence based techniques you
could just take the leaves viewing this
as a tree whichever of those techniques
you want to use and they all end up
looking surprisingly similar you can get
out a clustering an on-air very toy
dataset that clustering looks like this
which should be the clustering you
expected to get out of that toy dataset
but what about on more complex data what
about that test dataset I showed earlier
where we had the much more interesting
strange-looking probability density
function well this is the clustering you
would get out on that sort of data and
so even in the presence of a lot of
noise this approach behaves extremely
well all the data that's colored grey
there is data that this clustering
algorithm considered noise and said you
don't need to worry about this these are
not clusters just ignore that ignore
that data for now and so this is a
turns out a very very powerful
clustering algorithm that works very
well in practice okay what else could we
do well oddly enough I talked about all
those membership strengths we could ask
the question what's the probability in a
sense that any given data point is in
any connected component that's a fair
question to ask and it's trivial to
compute given what we've computed so far
the end result is that we can build a
heat map that looks like this on air
data this is the probability that the
data is in any connected component which
is essentially an anomaly detection
technique so the less likely the data is
to be in any connected component of a
probability density function the less
likely that it is to occur the more
normal as it is so all the data colored
dark purple and blue here is data that
this approach says is highly anomalous
but it's done more than that because
we've got a gradient within the data
that sort of custard there there's the
top left-hand cluster which it thinks is
sort of anomalous because it's not as
clumped as a lot of the other data in
general so it's a fairly smooth notion
and it's very interpretable it really is
just the probability that the data is in
any connected component of this
probability density function all right
so conclusions topology and category
theory which was the other language I
was pulling out there provide a
different language to frame these sorts
of problems than sort of standard
classical statistical thinking but these
are actually very powerful techniques
and they're worth using because they
help you transfer problems among
different ways of thinking about a
problem in nice natural ways and in
practice they can provide very effective
solutions that work on real world
datasets so so hopefully I've motivated
you to learn more that was really the
point of this talk you should look more
into these sorts of approaches because
they have real value but are often
overlooked thank you
[Applause]
have you published this somewhere so the
dimension reduction technique is
published and the code for it is in fact
open source and readily available on
github and in fact that algorithm was
recently included in Nvidia's rapids AI
program so you can even use it on GPUs
if you like the word and bidding is not
yet published as I said that's a work in
progress and the clustering there are
related clustering algorithms that can
be framed in almost exactly these terms
HDB scan would be the thing to look up
and that is published and there are
actually several papers on this
references I don't have them off the top
of my head come talk to me later and and
we can we can go through that okay thank
you could you recommend a book or some
small primer or like uuuuu brushed over
a lot of stuff in the first 20 minutes
for those of us who are interested in
going a little deeper where can we go I
that is an excellent question and I
apologize for brushing over a lot of
stuff in 20 minutes but I wanted to
cover both a little bit of the
motivating ideas and hopefully enough of
the practical applications to motivate
you actually look into it so assuming
that that seems to have worked at least
one book that is a good place to start
is called elementary applied topology by
Robert Grice it is on the math year side
but he does an excellent job of going
through these sorts of ideas in a very
slow sort of way with lots of pictures
he actually is an amazing illustrator as
well of extremely abstract concepts and
that's an excellent place for a sort of
broad introduction to these sorts of
topological ideas hey thanks for the
talk sorry the book was elementary
applied topology Robert Greist G H R ist
do you have problems with uniqueness of
connected components and how do you
handle that
like for instance even with persistence
with when you go to different level sets
and so on you might have different
connected components so oddly enough the
connected components all glue together
in a very nice way and it turns out that
if you do this in the category theoretic
approach it magically all glues it
together for you in exactly the way you
want otherwise you can actually just
glue them together as a tree the
connected components of level sets of
any sort of topological space turn out
to actually be representable as a graph
at the end of the day if you do it right
so in fact it actually all glues
together nicely and resolves itself so I
agree that is a complicated problem that
you could potentially have it turns out
that it all just works anyway you have
problems with uniqueness though what do
you mean by uniqueness you get different
connected components sometimes you mean
for different runs or different clusters
different together differently this
defines a notion of what should be a
cluster so you're bound by what the
algorithm will claim hi there you said
the code was on github could you point
me in the right direction for that yeah
okay so on github github.com /l McInnis
LM CI in in es /u map I know there's a
company called oz D that was trying to
do something similar they're trying to
apply topological techniques to problems
I mean do you have any sense of how
effective they are or like you know I
can't speak to that I don't have any
affiliation with Yazdi so I don't know
exactly what they're doing they have
different approaches that they are
applying I don't know how effective they
are they're for-profit company and they
seem to hold their cards pretty close to
their chest on what they're doing so I
can't speak to that
sorry of course does anyone have a
question okay let's
[Applause]